hey everybody this is International
master David proofs for chest comm and
today we're covering a really really
fundamental strategy for chest which is
how to attack on an open e file when you
have been so fortunate or clever as to
castle while your opponent has not and
the e-file becomes open the e-file of
course is the file of residence for both
Kings so how to attack when that file is
open and you Castle it and your opponent
hasn't obviously it's very favorable
situation for you but it's still good to
know how to knock him out right so this
being as fundamental as it is I'm doing
three different videos with examples on
it one classic video a Morphy massacre
and a second classic video which is
going to be more advanced in this video
which is covering a sign it's game but
this one here we're going to see a
pretty simple game in order to
illustrate the principles very simply
and clearly so first of all let's go
quickly through this opening a two
Knights defense black plays aggressively
leaving c6 undefended counter attacking
f2 and in this position you could still
play Bishop d7 to defend c6 but black
castles offering a sacrifice of material
which white accepts with Knight takes
pawn takes Bishop takes Knight takes and
then grabbing on c6 after all these
trades and further attacking the rook
and the pond so the first step in
attacking on an open E file is of course
to keep your opponent's king from
castling and thus far we have seen in my
video about how to prevent your opponent
from castling so the bishop comes to
this nice weak diagonal and why it's
going to have to figure out something to
do about their King but before he tends
to his King he decided to tend to the
hanging rook so white captures the rook
now black needs to develop an attack
here
okay so moves like Queen takes a8 aren't
quite going to cut it
okay White's going to play Queen d2 and
Knight to c3 and Castle queenside when
you play rook e8 he'll play f4 and you
can play off six trying to open up the
spy
but you're just not in time right Knight
c3 and you take and white will Castle to
safety or he could play Queen takes d5
check and trade Queens so on black here
needs to play a pretty threatening move
and actually he has a fantastic one to
start building his attack and initiative
not a super obvious move actually but
black can bring his queen to a square
from which it makes two threats to
threats are better than one and black is
now threatening to take on g2 which is
big because it would actually trap
White's rook potentially right and
prevent white from ever castling
kingside and to play Queen takes d5
check which would create the opening
file for attacking purposes
now here white has more than one
possible defense so let us just look at
one or two possible moves for white
first Queen to d5 now black has more
than one good move he can play here one
nice move is just to come to the open
file with the point that if white takes
black and play checkmate but I believe
this move actually fails to this tricky
move from white blocking the Queen's
attack and if black takes the Queen
white will take the Queen and remain
ahead of rook and if black takes the
pawn instead white will take the rook
and checkmate the black King on the back
rank so rogue d8 looks very nice but I
think what black needs to do here is
play Queen check almost checkmating the
white king the Queen's force back and
now Queen takes b2 attacking the rook
and the pawn on e5 if black captures the
rook then material is already equal so
the most obvious move we need to
consider for white is Knight d2 that
move fails to a simple checkmate on the
e-file right so there you have it first
way to win with an attack on the open e
file a simple criss-crossed checkmate so
that deals with Queen takes pawn on d5
so white's other
good defenses our Knights III and Queen
d2 so nicely threes played in the game
so we'll look at Queen d2 first and
black will take this pawn with check and
the white king could boogie or white
could block with his queen if the White
King just sort of heads over this way
there's more than one nice thing the
black could do but actually basically
the simplest thing for black to do would
be to just capture this Bishop because
now you've got a situation where you're
not down very much material you've got a
bishop against a rook and the white King
is stuck in the center for good and
furthermore you've got threats like
Queen takes b2 and 94 so that is like
the simplest approach and it will
certainly lead to a winning position for
black so we need five Czech Queen III
blacks now going to play Queen takes b2
and white can't capture black's knight
because of queen c1 checkmate so in this
position white can really give up with a
safe conscience about that there was no
defense available so the game continues
with the move Knight to c3 and now black
is going to open the e-file that's
always step two Queen takes e5 check now
very important the white King can't run
away because black has the move Queen f4
check forcing him back onto the open E
file and now rook e8 finishing him off
because the only piece that can block is
the knight and the bishop is also on
that square so that wins for black he
could take with his rook he could take
with this bishop he could attack the
knight in extra time with his queen he
could do whatever there okay so king d2
is not really defense the white plays
his Knight to e2 to block the file so
now we have the typical scenario where
you have an open attack on the e-file
and the key is very very often going to
be how many times you can attack the
piece that's going to block the file so
Black has nicely coordinated already
with the bishop and the Queen on e - the
key thing you want to calculate is do
you have enough pieces attacking e - so
that if your opponent castled you could
win the piece on e - in this position
the answer is already yes Black has two
attackers and white has two defenders
and one of them is the king so if white
castles the night will be undefended so
the best thing to do here for black is
you simply capture that Bishop on a
eight and if white castles you'll
capture on e two and you'll have two
pieces against a rook in the endgame
which is enough to win if you know how
to play the endgame good luck with that
um so black captures this piece and
white is now going to struggle around
trying to get an extra defender on to e2
so that he can then evacuate his King
one thing you'll sometimes see people do
is play like f3 King f2 and bring their
rook over the thing that white does in
the game is he plays f4 to try and gain
one extra temp on the Queen compared to
that but let's look at f3 for a moment
so if white plays f3 what should black
do the first thing you want to look at
is can you just attack this piece enough
times to capture and win it the second
thing you would look for is can you
prevent King f2 so if you thought of
Queen e3 that's in the right direction
of things you should be looking at but
actually you're looking the wrong order
first you want to look at rook e8 and
see if White has any defense for its
night on e - and the answer is he
doesn't okay and this is the simplest
way to win you just pile up on that
piece and when you get to you know three
attackers to two defenders you take it
so in the game white plays f4 and the
black Queen moves to e4
now if white moves his King to f2 to try
and bring his rook over what should
black do about this
the answer is you have to do a little
calculation the first thing to look at
was of course rook to e8 and then you
saw white can defend with rook to e1 you
look if you have any kind of follow-up
there you can also look for moves that
would prevent this by trying to check
the white King so for example this move
here is a totally good move to think of
followed by taking this pawn with check
right and you're hoping to force the
white king back onto the first rank to
keep his rook from coming out and then
you know he would block with his Queen
you would play Knight e4 check and you
will actually force the white King back
to the first rank and get probably a
winning position for black because if
white is unable to get his rooks around
his King this Knight is going to
continue to be better than either of his
rooks and black will have a winning
attack but the simplest approach here
for black is actually to calculate the
rook e8 move an extra step after rook to
e1 you can check the white king keeping
it from running into the corner the
white king is forced back to f1 and then
you follow in with Knight to e4 which is
even stronger than taking this pawn with
check right you don't want to make his
King move away you move your knight in
threatening checkmate and white cannot
defend himself the only move that you
might be thinking looks like a defense
is Queen here but black would capture it
and then I can't recapture because of
this diagonal so after F for Queen e4
white did not try moving his King
because of that checkmating attack
instead he brings the rook over to
defend the knight from f2 now what move
should you look at first for black
before you look at trying to prevent
white's idea you look at you know can I
just build up and win by attacking this
so that is actually how you can win so
black plays rook to e8 allows white to
bring his rook to a good defensive
square and now black is just going to
bring in an extra attacking unit okay
this is really really the key if your
opponent has any ability to defend they
will have you know two or three pieces
that will defend e to you will bring the
first wave of your forces to a medet and
then you'll reach a little bit of a
stalemate now it's a long
rode for this rook to get into the game
that gives you some time but what you
need to figure out is a way to get extra
attackers okay sometimes you can find
extra angles of attack like if on this
move here you had tried taking on g2 and
sort of open opening up more of this
area of the board to find extra angles
to attack the white king that's
definitely one valid approach but the
most common approach is that you just
find a way to beat up on this even more
and so one option is to move the knight
to e6 and then to d4 or f4 it's very
logical right Stremme bring this knight
to attack white tonight it turns out
there's an even easier way which couples
with a second technique which you always
want to do which is to open more lines
right so black plays d4 here the idea is
that black will play d3 bring you a new
attacker on the night so let me make a
passing move for white black will play
d3 new attack around the knight white
takes it black brings in a new attacker
with the knight
now this Knight isn't attacking e 2 but
after say White's King moves you know
you're removing the defender by taking
the rook and it's a massacre right so
what you see here is a mix of trying to
bring in more pieces and also opening
new lines right by trading the two pawns
like this you've opened new space with
from which to attack white so in this
position white has absolutely no move
that stops d3 is such a good move if he
moves his King off of the file he's
still on the diagonal right so you still
played d3 attacking the knight and when
he takes you take with the night and
you're threatening Knight takes f2
there's just no defense here the rook
can move and then the knight could come
to be 2 attacking the Queen or f4
attacking you too and White's going to
lose the piece on e2 eventually that's
been so focused on by black okay but
it's really really important that you
have some kind of focus in your attacks
and not just attack randomly all over
the place so I mean the game just ended
with white playing b4 and black playing
his Knight to a4 you know you could also
calculate d3 with a strong attack but
Knight a 4 is so good because you
also happy to bring your Knight to c3
right and on white just resigned because
you can't stop Knight c3 and the knight
on YouTube will die so that is how to
manage an attack on an open e file with
the most straightforward of methods just
bringing every piece to bear on whatever
is blocking that file right and the
technique of opening up new lines when
necessary and the technique of doing
some calculating we will also have a
more complex example so you can check
for that under classic games I hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess calm